10,330 feather players need to see this
video. So, you have a feather deck
because you just want to cast the same
five cards over and over and over again,
fisting and fisting. No problem. I
understand 100 cards is maybe too much
information. So, you probably didn't
have the brain space to find this card.
Intimidation bolt, did you? To be fair,
there's definitely the shock factor of
playing with yourself. Your opponents
will be immobilized for a moment, like,
is he really doing this in public? Some
may even enjoy it. But let's be honest,
they are most likely smarter than you
with their wrinkled brains. They
understand that feather will be
untouchable if the game goes on. So they
begin to pressure your life total. That
is feather's one weakness. The jig is up
and what do you do now? Oh yeah, you can
block with feather, but what if they
have two creatures or even three? Did
not think of that, did you? This is
where intimidation bolt comes in. And
now we need a little bit of thinking
outside the box to understand this one.
Just a little. Okay, I see half of you
have switched off the video, but it's
okay. We still have 5,165 of you here.
And it's not going to be easy. Let's
take it slow. You see, it's not about
the damage. It's about the second
sentence. Other creatures can't attack
this turn. So, you bolt feather because
she has four toughness and damage clears
at the end of turn. And this spell
targets so you get it back. So, you can
keep zapping feather and never be
attacked again. Spicy. Uh, but locking
down three opponents cost nine mana. I
still have to do the fisting thing. Yes,
because you let your opponents develop.
Did you know that there are also board
wipes that work with f? Okay, never
mind. I don't want to overwhelm with too
much information.